hey I'm Dan Perrault San Diego Comic Con
where it seems like every day there's a
new piece of Star Wars news including
the fact that Daniel Radcliffe will play
a young Han Solo that's not true nor is
anything I'm about to say let's do this
alright I'm here with Calvin obviously a
huge Star Wars fan now Calvin what are
you wearing who you dressed as today I'm
a my own character long-lost cousin of
obi-wan Kenobi my name is qu Don Kenobi
who Don can all be very cool a little
shocking today to hear that John
Williams is not returning for Episode
seven instead it's Darius Rucker from
hootie and the blowfish doing the score
what are your thoughts on this news I'm
a little disheartened I do know that the
composer that worked with JJ Abrams
stood aside because JJ Abrams really
used as a composer for all of his work
it was just announced today that Elsa
will be Pam Ewing in Episode eight what
are your thoughts on that you know
that's a really interesting choice yeah
is she like am I like in the background
like it's a major character oh really
now some pretty crazy casting news one
direction will start and the new Star
Wars Episode movie do you know what
their characters are here Jedi's they
make up the new Jedi Temple yeah younger
generation do it and I can applaud their
effort because they're trying to get
that yeah and it was announced today
that Star Wars and Star Trek are gonna
crossover starting in 2019 do you think
that's a good direction I mean I think
they're very different and I like them
separately for separate reasons Disney
announced today that they're doing a
comedy spin-off the Star Wars featuring
Darth Vader and Boba Fett as roommates
do you think that's a good idea
George Lucas is doing it there is talk
of recasting the entire original trilogy
with Channing Tatum as Han Solo with
Jennifer Lawrence as Princess Leia and
Channing Tatum as Luke Skywalker do you
think that wait Channing Tatum is one so
he's doing both he can do everything
that's true
Channing Tatum twice yeah he's that good
Channing Tatum Channing Tatum I mean
Taylor Swift is rumored to have a cameo
in the new Star Wars movie is that a
good direction for the series I could be
is she singing in the cantina yeah
oh she sings she sings most of her songs
we are never never getting back together